hello and welcome everyone to yet
another tech enthusiastic video from
simply learn today we will learn about
abstract classes in Java but before we
begin please subscribe to the simply
learn youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update on the
trending technologies in the current IT
industry also if you're interested in
learning more about the Java programming
language then please visit the simply
learn official website where you can
learn more about Java and its latest
trends in the current IT now without
further ado let us quickly start with
our agenda for today's session
first we will have a brief discussion
about abstract classes more like an
introduction next we will discuss the
major features of the abstract classes
that give it an edge in the
object-oriented programming
followed by that we will discuss the
crucial rules to be followed to use
abstract classes next in the docket we
will understand the definition of
abstraction and the ways through which
we can achieve it later we will have a
briefing about the interface which also
acts as a means to achieve abstraction
once we have the right understanding of
an abstract class and an interface we
will head directly into executing some
of the examples based on abstract
classes to understand the concept in a
much better way after this we will learn
some of the key differences between the
abstract class and an interface finally
we will wind up the session by
understanding the major advantages and
disadvantages of abstract classes I hope
I have made myself clear over the agenda
now our first topic what is an abstract
class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object-oriented
programming approach and designing a
software here the programmer tries to
hide the complicated implementation of
the code which makes the software run
smoothly most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it to do so we use an
abstract laws or sometimes an interface
based on the requirement so abstract
class in Java is considered as a
template of methods and variables which
are used in a program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly now moving ahead
we will next learn the important
features of abstract classes
so the first one is template the main
reason program is preferred to use
abstract methods as because they act as
a predefined template for any future
specific class that you might use next
loose coupling is a procedure where an
internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world nullus other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible after that we have the code
reusability implementation of the
abstract classes provides the developers
with one of the greatest features that
saves time which is none other than the
code reusability followed by code
reusability we have abstraction as
discussed earlier later abstraction is
the process of hiding certain details
and showing only essential information
to the user abstraction can be achieved
with either a char classes or interfaces
last but not the least dynamic method
resolution the abstract classes enable
us with dynamic method resolution or the
dynamic method dispatch process the
dynamic method resolution is a mechanism
by which a call to an overridden method
is resolved at runtime this is how Java
implements runtime polymorphism when an
overridden method is called by reference
the Java determines which version of
that method to execute based on the type
of object it refers to now these were
the few important features of abstract
classes next in the docket is the
crucial rules to be followed to use
abstract classes alright let us go
through the rules one by one as
mentioned below the first one is the
keyword abstract is mandatory to declare
an abstract class followed by that the
next rule says that after our classes
cannot be instantiated directly the
third one is an abstract class must have
at least one abstract
next to that we have another rule which
says an abstract class includes final
methods next an abstract class may also
include known a fragment it's it's not
mandatory that an abstract class should
only include abstract methods so the
last rule says that an abstract class
can include constructors and static
methods so these were some crucial rules
to be followed to use abstract classes
in Java so far we have discussed the
definition of abstract classes its
features and the rules to use abstract
classes in Java now we will learn how to
achieve abstraction in Java so basically
there are two different ways to achieve
abstraction in Java
the first way is by using abstract
classes and the next one is by using an
interface now this brings us to our next
topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract
followed by that we use the keyword
called class then after that we declare
the name of our class the name of the
class is out to the user's choice for
example I have named my class as simply
learn as shown here followed by the
abstract class we have the abstract
method to declare an abstract method we
use the keyword called abstract then the
return type of the method as of now I
have used void then later we have the
name of the method that is based on the
user's choice as you can see I have used
simply learn as the name of the method
so this was by using abstract class
method the next one is by using an
interface method
now what exactly is an interface so
interface can be defined as a boundary
between the method and the class
implementing it in Java we use interface
to achieve abstraction in other words we
can also consider interface as a
container which saves the signatures of
the methods used in a program now we
will move ahead and understand the
syntax to use an interface to achieve
abstraction in Java radicular an
interface we use the keyword call
interface followed by that we declare
the name of a class the class name is up
to the user's choice for example I have
mean my class as simply learn as shown
below as discussed earlier interface
acts just as a container that stores
only the signatures of the method we
cannot have a complete method defined
inside it all we can do is just declare
an interface now that we have a detail
explanation above the abstract class and
interface let us look into some example
programs based on abstract classes now
we have successfully booted the Eclipse
IDE now let's create a new project so to
create a new project just click on
create a project and this should give
you a dialog box wherein you have to
select Java project
click Next now let us give a known to
our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this process
as you can see the project has been
successfully created and inside the
project simply alone we have the source
file and right clicking the source file
will give us a drop box where you can
just select new and inside new you can
select a new package now let's name the
package past abstraction and click on
finish to create the package
moving further let's right-click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class so
the name of my class will be employed
let's click on finish to create the
class now we have our employ class ready
now let's right-click on the package and
select new and inside that let us select
another class and the name of this
particular class will be person which
will act as our abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person so our first example which is
based on employees where we will have an
abstract class called person and this
person class will be inherited by the
employee class and gets executed to
generate employed details now let us try
to execute this program and see the
output
to execute the program just right click
on the package and go to the run option
and select the first one that is java
application
now you can see we have the employee
named Pavitra and the gender is female
and the employee has logged in
successfully so these are the details
which we were expecting to be presented
on the output console now moving ahead
we shall execute our next example which
will be based on students so here the
class student is the abstract class and
three different student classes namely
Raju
ronita and poet will inherit the student
class and generate the output that
displays their particular ranks so you
can see our abstract class that a
student is being declared using the
keyword abstract and inside that we have
an abstract method which is get ranked
and these classes Dada
Raju pronita and poet will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks now let us try to execute this
program and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console now let us move ahead and
try to execute one last example based on
abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks here we have an abstract class
named loan and all the banks described
in the program will inherit the loan
abstract class to calculate the rate of
interest on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is loan and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we had the classes Andhra
Bank Bank of Baroda ID BC Bank State
Bank of India which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output console
so with this we have entered into our
next topic where we understand the
differences between an abstract class
and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword while we declare an
interface we use the keyword called
interface on the other hand when we
declare an abstract class we use the
keyword abstract followed by that the
second difference is when you use an
interface the subclasses basically
implement an interface while on the
other hand when you use abstract classes
the subclasses extend an abstract class
and inherit the properties of the
abstract class followed by that the
third difference is multiple interfaces
can be implemented but on the other hand
only one half shot class can be extended
at one particular instance and the final
difference between the both s interface
is capable to support multiple
inheritance whereas on the other hand
abstract classes are not capable to
support multiple inheritances multiple
inheritance is none other than the
diamond problem which is not supported
in Java now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract loss
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in Java are the abstract classes
are highly beneficial in writing shorter
codes the abstract classes avoid code
duplication they enable code reusability
which is a major advantage and finally
the last advantage is changes to the
internal code implementation can be done
without affecting the classes so these
were few of the major advantages of
using an abstract class now moving ahead
we shall discuss the disadvantages of
using abstract classes few of the
disadvantages of using an abstract class
in Java are abstraction is expensive as
sometimes you need to handle cases and
situations which are not necessary
followed by that the second disadvantage
is
object-relational impedance must match
in the case of our DBMS and the last
disadvantage is object relational
mapping in case of frameworks like
hibernate so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in Java that you need to consider before
using them into your project now with
this we have come to an end of this
session on abstract classes in Java
I hope this session was helpful if you
have any queries based on the abstract
classes in Java or any questions related
to the java programming language then
please feel free to drop them down in
the comment section below and we will
have your questions answered by our
experts as soon as possible
it's robby signing off and don't forget
to get subscribe to our channel and hit
the ville icon to receive important
updates on the trending technologies
thank you until next time
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here